buckle up welcome to hannity so much
breaking news
that i promise you won't get anywhere
else i want to start tonight though with
a
thank you to you the viewers of the show
and this network
you continue to make the show not only
possible but number one
in all of cable news now
going on our third year we do not ever
take it for granted
and one of the things we promise you is
unlike the
hate trump media mob we are working hard
every single day with a
great ensemble cast here to bring you
truth
every single night every single week we
will continue to do so
thank you for all your support but we
can report tonight
act one is over in spite of the noise
robert mueller is out the witch hunt has
been dissolved he said
nothing today that wasn't already said
in the mueller report
so act two which is surrounding the deep
state's unprecedented abuse of power and
corruption
that is now only beginning that means
jim comey
john clapper james clapper
john brennan and others they are
terrified
they know they're in big trouble and
we'll have a lot on this throughout the
hour tonight but first
at this hour what you are hearing from
the democrats
they're well pet parrots in the media
mob
is nothing more than dumb idiotic noise
only noise per usual ongoing hysteria
not about truth not about facts you've
had two years of lies and hoaxes and
conspiracy
theories peddled every second every
minute every hour of every day
and it's just one more round of
lying tin foil hack conspiracy theories
trump bashing over a narrative that is
totally
dead and buried because tonight well the
fact remains
there was no trump russia
collusion there was no obstruction
nothing has changed
mueller spent 20 plus months 25 plus
million dollars
investigating a hoax and now for the
fourth time we have a conclusion
no collusion no conspiracy now today he
officially resigned
from the office of special counsel but
not before showing the world of course
what we already knew on this program his
partisan
hackery true colors if you will
you have a career bureaucrat nothing
more than a trump-hating partisan
who is now all but cheering for
impeachment
based on nothing and we were right the
entire time
watch this if we had had
confidence that the president clearly
did not commit a crime we would have
said so
we did not however make a determination
as to whether the president did commit a
crime
the constitution requires a process
other than the criminal justice system
to formally accuse a sitting president
of wrongdoing
number one mr mueller doesn't know the
law he's basically full of crap
and the special counsel's regulations
they are very clear
according to the law remember we got rid
of the independent council act
oh because people like gerald nadler
didn't want the ken starr report
with 11 specific felonies listed even
made public so they changed the law that
means
the attorney general of the united
states under nadler and company's new
law
he has the final say and we already know
his answer
the attorney general barr the deputy
attorney general rod rosenstein
the nonpartisan office of legal counsel
all crystal clear on this matter they
all concluded
the president did not obstruct justice
not
because of some justice department rule
or guideline
or some constitutional restriction they
actually were very clear on this point
but because there was no crime period
so make no mistake this is no cover-up
and according to a statement from the
doj tonight despite the special
counsel's rhetoric
there is no conflict between barr and
mueller about this matter
in america you know we live in a country
where the burden of proof is
always on the state now i know we live
in a world where media
will convict a 16 year old kid and not
even make a phone call to get to any of
the facts
but the reality is in this country you
are innocent until proven guilty
it is a fundamental basic constitutional
right
and as the president just stated on
twitter quote nothing changes from the
mueller report
it was insufficient evidence therefore
in our country a person is innocent this
case is closed
thank you he's right mueller's continued
public smear of a duly elected president
who has been charged with no crime
is completely unethical and immoral we
will explain all of this in detail
and mueller's actions today had nothing
to do with justice
everything to do with politics and his
pressure today served one purpose
and that was to help the democrats yet
give them another political bone to chew
on
bone has no meat there's no underlying
crime there's no evidence of guilt
just more innuendo more speculation
surrounding what we now know as a
total conspiracy theory compare that to
the star report which i mentioned
earlier
under the independent council statute
well independent council ken starr
he actually outlined 11. look right
there specific crimes
committed by then president bill clinton
five counts of lying under oath
four counts of obstruction one count of
witness tampering
one count of abuse of constitutional
authority
president clinton lost his law license
he was impeached and he had to pay paula
jones nearly a million dollars
because of the specific crimes uncovered
by star
yet today we see a much different
picture
mueller is now just cheering for the
president's impeachment over
phantom obstructive justice with no
intent
no underlying crime and these same
people screaming all over television
today
are not the people that would ever say
hillary violated 18 usc
793 the espionage act and then when she
deleted the 33 000 subpoenaed emails
yeah and then she bleach fit the hard
drive and then she had an aide bust up
her devices and pull out sim cards
oh the intention was clear which was to
destroy the evidence of the underlying
crime
why don't anybody why doesn't anybody in
the media
ever point that out if you are wondering
whether or not mueller
is open to transparency accountability
in his deeply flawed investigation think
again watch this
i do not believe it is appropriate for
me to speak further about the
investigation or to comment
on the actions of the justice department
or congress
and it's for that reason i will not be
taking questions today as well
oh bob mueller does not want to answer
questions of jim jordan mark meadows
matt gates
and other republicans and have to answer
for why
he hearted he hired only democratic
donors
big time donors why for example did
robert mueller i'd like to see him
answer this question
why in an investigation would you have
hired hillary clinton's former
attorney for the clinton foundation
jeannie ray
why did you hire a man named andrew
weissman your pitbull according to the
new york times
who has nothing but a long track record
oh licensed to lie sidney powell
of withholding exculpatory evidence of
losing tens of thousands of americans
jobs in the enron case
being beaten down 9-0 in the u.s supreme
court
putting four mayoral executives in jail
for a year and that was overturned by
the fifth circuit
how did you hire that guy and by the way
he
also attended andrew weissman hillary
clinton's
victory party on election night 2016
not one republican donor by the way a
hillary clinton super fan
investigating her political rival why
didn't mueller hire
any republican donors when did mueller
determine there was no collusion i'd
like that question answered
and why was he more interested in farrah
and taxi medallions
and loan applications and taxes than he
was about a dirty russian dossier
with russian disinformation that an
opposition party candidate
paid for and then was used to spy on the
opposition party
that oh people that you hired said
should win 100 million to zero
that trump was lonesome oh and they had
an insurance policy
just in case donald trump win why did
you hire him
uh mr mueller why did you hire struck
and paige why did it take
michael horowitz to reveal the text
because you didn't do it
and you wiped their phones clean how
many months did the special counsel
pursue
a perjury trap obstruction charges
after the president was cleared of all
underlying crimes how did you have time
to get into a
fairer violation of medallions and loan
applications
yet at no time did you mr mueller
dare to investigate the very root of
this
entire hoax hillary clinton's dirty
russian dossier put together by a
foreign spy
that's not supposed to influence our
elections who by the way
doesn't stand by his own dossier the new
york times is suggesting
likely russian disinformation isn't that
closer to the original mandate that rod
rosenstein gave you
did you even care that hillary clinton
paid a foreign spy
to interfere in our election and use
russian lies
did you even care that your buddy james
comey
used hillary's russian dossier to spy
not only on an american citizen and they
spy it in other ways also
but to go before a fisa court and lie by
omission and not tell the court that
hillary paid for those lies
also not verify what was in the dossier
we now know it was unverifiable because
the guy that wrote the dossier
doesn't stand by it and says he has no
idea if any of it's true
we the american people deserve answers
to these questions
i want mueller under oath i want him
held accountable
i want him answering those questions it
is now more important than ever
senator lindsey graham summed it up
perfectly act one is over
the mueller witch-hunt is done complete
whether they like it or not but now act
two
the curtain is rising take a look
do you share my concerns about the fisa
warrant process
yes do you share my concerns about the
counterintelligence investigation how it
was opened and why it was opened
yes you share my concerns that the
professional
lack of professionalism and the clinton
email investigation is something we
should all look at
yes do you expect to change your mind
about the bottom line
conclusions of the mueller report no do
you think the president's campaign in
2016
was thoroughly looked at in terms of
whether or not they colluded with the
russians
yes and the answer is no according to
bob mueller
that's right he couldn't decide about
obstruction you did is that correct
that's right you feel good about your
decision absolutely
now despite what you just heard
democrats just can't
let go of their two years of lying their
two years of a hoax their two years of
conspiracy theories
nor can their best friends in the media
mob and robert mueller's speech today
was frankly just another spark to
reinvigorate
one more final time what is an
impeachment fantasy
now without a doubt the radical extreme
democratic socialist party
they are clamoring for impeachment more
than ever before
here's my message to them tonight go for
it
go for it i want you to reach for the
stars i want you to stay on your new
green deal that gets rid of oil gas the
combustion engine
cows and planes and everything's free
and whether you're willing or unwilling
to work and i want you to stay on
impeachment you just stay right there
and don't solve any problems for the
american people or serve
the people that put you in washington
because i know most on the left you're
probably not smart enough to realize
that the handwriting is on the wall if
you think
november 2016 was bad if you think the
mueller report was
bad and you can't handle that truth well
your quest for
impeachment is political suicide
and i'm going to kind of enjoy watching
you dig the hole deeper every day
because if democrats pursue this sick
dream of theirs
the election is going to be for donald
trump
in a landslide he will win easily a
second term
and the party of fdr uh well people like
scoop jackson and joe lieberman
will forever be marginalized as a
radical group
of socialist extremists that don't care
about the american people
or making us more safe and more secure
and more prosperous
so my advice to speaker pelosi who's
speaker in name only
give into the temptation give in to the
ocasio-cortez
wing of the party and frankly i think
you're probably going to because you
know otherwise they're going to kick you
out the door
because really we know the real speaker
is radical freshman lawmakers
will stop at nothing to rip this country
apart at its core
but no matter what happens in the
democratic party tonight
whether they in the media want to face
simple basic fundamental truth
the russia hoax is dead mueller's issues
are dead and the truth is on the march
and with the declassification last week
i'm going to sit back and enjoy every
night saying as we've been telling you
for the last
two years here's the evidence because
it's all coming out
the president all of it the fisa
applications the 302s the gang of eight
the exculpatory evidence it's all coming
out
there's no stopping it it's not if it's
when